both doing good brother
I have to start with where in Brazil and
si si XP was absolutely insane the hell
was that experience like for you guys
bizarre I mean max danger well yeah
we're warming the backstage I was so
nervous like I was literally shaking and
all of them were like I never relaxed
and then I got out but the energy is not
it doesn't overpower you it's like a
really welcoming scream it's like
they're they're welcoming you and all of
a sudden I was like I feel more
comfortable up here then they did it was
really cool yeah it was something I have
to start with for me the opening of this
movie the car chase is ludicrous it's so
so crazy and I've seen a lot of movies I
have never seen anything like this in
Italy ever yeah so I have to ask you
that's about filming this thing because
I heard it was like a month-long shoot
yeah we filmed that for a month um and
it was first we started me and Melanie
in the car then Dave jumped in the car
and we were there for like a pretty long
time and then Ryan got on the carcass
there always had to be a camera
placement but we were all stuck in there
together going up I don't know how many
miles an hour every single day every
single hour of the day so it was both
like emotionally exhausting because
we're honestly terrified the majority of
the time like it was it was so real sure
we were non we're nuns you know no
special effects
no no green-screen
we were in the streets of Italy and me
and Melanie don't have seatbelts on the
back look at me I was enjoying my pasta
with my wine watching the car
it's crazy okay so I want to switch um
I've been on set with Michael Bay I've
seen the way Michael Bay works did it's
he's in a unique individual yeah I
definitely want to know if you can share
a fun story or a surprising story about
working with them I mean for me just
even the first day when I shot with him
and it was like three people it felt
like a student film yeah him with his
camera and he didn't want anybody and
said and it was like this small location
and I'm like is this a Michael Bay film
I thought it was gonna be like hundreds
and it makes it look huge and him doing
the camera he's pulling the cables he
made everything
he's a hands man I'm like so for me that
was something like that
you know it surprised me most of the
time I'm used to the director being in
his little blogs you know or the monitor
and he's like right there with you you
ended my lighting ones as well you want
it okay I'm holding the light here and
then I'm like we were in the core and it
kept coming into the shots I'm like
pushing the blue he's like yeah that's
crazy the other thing though is he he
will do way more setups in a typical
director so what what is it like
actually doing that because I know I
think you mentioned there was like a
hundred and something setups in one day
or someone yeah I mean 50 it's something
so something particularly yeah I mean
for people that don't realize like a
typical day you we're lucky did you make
it 20 yeah like so what is that like as
an actor it's exhausting Owen
yeah but it's it's so it's his Energy's
contagious you just go with it and now I
you go to another film set I'm like what
what is everyone doing why is everyone
waiting around like I don't understand
it and they come from you know I'm just
doing a Michael Bay movie where it's
like go go go you don't stop you're
lucky if you remember to eat you're like
oh wait have I eaten like no maybe I
should go to like you just don't you
just keep going
so fine this file time is just fun you
guys filmed around the world what is the
place if you could go back to tomorrow
where would you go and why Florence
is it the wine or the food everything
the wine the food that people already
the aren't yeah it's just beautiful and
Sienna yeah yeah it's you know we didn't
get to spend that much time because I
was in the car in the car do you
remember because I obviously I'm not
talking to Michael for this do you
remember if there's like a lot of
deleted scenes stuff that you shot I
mean assuming you've seen the finished
film yes
yeah I'm just making sure yeah um yeah
like and I think any movie Michael you
just said a Michael dozen hundred and
fifty setups a day I think there's no
way that he's gonna do you know he's
gonna do the longest movie in the
history of cinema if he were to use
every single set up every single day um
so yeah definitely there was things that
got missed out of out of the movie but
you kind of in every film you okay yeah
yeah yeah but yeah yeah definitely but I
just can't remember we're like so it
wasn't like something big plot point no
no no no no it was just like be you know
the old beats there and I just remember
one in the elevator then they had a line
well we all had like a interaction there
and it was very funny I'm like man this
didn't make it to but it was so cool oh
no you're nothing that the elevator
you're waiting and it didn't make it but
it was a fun thing oh when you Ryan and
payment yeah
it was just so funny and it didn't make
it so yeah just little bits but nothing
like to you know to compromise the
plotter